this week's 48 hours investigates the
disappearance of a mother of three maya
malette vanished from her southern
california home in january 2021 shortly
after friends and family began to grow
suspicious of her husband larry
investigators say the couple had been
having marital issues and they say larry
had been contacting so-called spell
casters to try and put a hex on maya to
keep maya in the marriage 48 hours
contributor jonathan bigliotti has more
more than a year has gone by since 39
year old maya meliete vanished in chula
vista california i want her to be found
i want to bring her home to her kids to
our families maya's sister mary chris
and her husband richard julie
when did you notice something
was wrong she's planning for her
daughter's birthday and we haven't heard
anything from her this is not her at all
maya who worked for the navy along with
her husband larry was last heard from on
january 7 2021
when mary chris and richard showed up at
their house larry told them she was out
larry says
maya's been where hiking she went hiking
billy little a former criminal defense
investigator for the navy helped maya's
family in the early days and talked to
larry about his wife's disappearance he
was unconcerned about his wife being
gone he said this wasn't all that
unusual for her i didn't have the
answers at that point but i was very
suspicious
little says he learned that the couple
had been having marital problems and
that larry had turned to some unusual
methods to get her to stay he went on
the internet found a website that does a
witchcraft cast spells
he wrote can you hex to have her heard
enough that she will have to depend on
me maybe an accident or broken bone
that's really hard to hear
after an investigation by law
enforcement larry maliete was arrested
on october 19
2021 for the murder of his wife larry
has pleaded not guilty and still insists
maya left on her own maya's friend and
colleague claudia hulo do you think maya
left that house on her own
the search continues to find maya and
bring closure to her family there's
somebody out there that knows something
have it in your heart to help us bring
it home
[Music]
and jonathan vigliotti joins us now
jonathan good morning uh what i mean
this story is so disturbing using spells
and hexes uh but what are some of the
unconventional methods that larry tried
to use to control maya
yeah what really stands out to me and
you just touched on it and we touched on
it and the piece you just watched is the
use of spell casting which is exactly as
it sounds larry went online he hired
people paid them to cast spells on his
wife initially asking for his wife to
fall back in love with him over time
when that did not happen he asked for
harm to be brought to her so she
physically could not leave his side he
created altars where what appeared to be
blood splattered on photos of him and
her at one point he even left a review
for one of these spellcasters calling
her kind and courteous the kind of thing
that you'd almost leave a review for a
restaurant on yelp
how do you prosecute against a hex or
casting a hex on someone but i'm
that's a whole other story i'm sure
jonathan but
what what is he saying in his defense
he's pleading not guilty he pleaded not
guilty he maintains that maya left on
her own but evidence suggests otherwise
there was surveillance video in the
neighborhood where maya lives showing
her arriving home the night it is
believed she was killed that same video
does not show her
at any point leaving that house
jonathan bigliotti for us thank you
jonathan appreciate it thank you you can
see jonathan's disturbing report
searching for maya miate on 48 hours
tomorrow night at 10 9 central right
here on cbs and on our streaming service
paramount plus we'll be right back